so you know every story has an origin
and I mean this one has got a long
backstory can you guys tell us a little
bit how this thing came to life yeah so
we spent 10 years working on this movie
yeah it started the first draft was we
started we wrote it in 2009 and then
there was about a hundred and sixty
subsequent drafts but and I say that and
I so for all the writers in the audience
as a lesson you know and the three or
four times it was a page one rewrite
more every day always died at the end
that was something this is a parable we
we know he needed to die at the end but
uh
manok there's more drafts but I've
changed computers a few times so I
probably lost a couple over 10 years
that happens it started initially with
this kind of with a a nostalgic sense it
was a burning desire to kind of put
these pulp nonfiction x' that our dad
would tell because he worked in the
diamond district for a runner slash
salesman who was not not Howard you know
he was kind of like you know he was a
dreamer and he was over a compensator
and he you know was just trying to earn
his place but but it was not the
character oh and still living I hope he
our dads yes our dad is yes the the guy
who worked for haven't been able to get
in touch with him I wanted to show him
the movie haven't been able to get in
touch with him but he was kind of when I
reconnected with him he's like your dad
owes me three thousand dollars and he
was quick to tell me that oh but but
yeah so you know over the ten years you
know you you you know we wrote the film
with Raul Bronstein and and you know we
at some point this plot and the fiction
becomes part of your life and if you
were to look at my journals over the
past ten years there's bizarre cuz it's
just Howard this Howard that but there
it's my life I'm saying Howard in
regards to my own life so I'm spinning
my own experiences through the fiction
and trying to understand like what I'm
going through and and things ideas I'm
having so it it's tough it's tough to
allocate how this thing becomes so
layered yeah and because everything is
thought-out and in addition to that it's
like there was this it was this wait
like we wanted to make this movie it was
gonna be thought oh we're gonna be 78
years old by the time but at what ended
up happening was there's nothing wrong
with being said you know I'm saying but
when you absolutely not I'm saying well
no I'm not saying that I was saying that
when we started at 20 years ago that's
gonna take us 50 years to make this
thing that's when it's gonna finally get
there what ended up happening though is
you make this movie and like okay after
we make daddy longlegs their first form
like all right uncut gems is next and
then you or if you think you've arrived
and but I think nope sorry you can't do
that like the the culture at large you
know Hollywood at large say you're not
allowed to do that yet so then you make
a movie that's related you know it was a
documentary about a basketball player so
you make all these twists and turns but
it ends up deepening your ideas and your
the thought process and how things go
and educational details yes every film
was an education to make this one better
he went out didn't know we we had if we
had us on our first film ours it was a
small film we had at the Cannes Film
Festival and we thought we were gonna I
was 25 at the time and I was just like
you know which is absurd to think and we
thought we could take that modicum of
success and go after Adam Sandler and we
had no right to go after Adam Sandler we
didn't earn him that right and thus like
Adam to weigh in on that Howard Howard
always died and we always wanted Adam
because we knew that would movie
wouldn't work without yes but speaking
of you know Adam Sandler and you know so
that you said they say they approached
you at candid that actually happened no
I mean and I never I never talked to him
I never and for I do apologize for the
way I'm dressed I know it doesn't look
good my kid my kid has a Spanish test
tomorrow I was studying Spanish whether
I kept saying I gotta get I gotta change
and she always I know but for Pedro a
coat on I've been here one other time I
swear to God a nice jacket I was ready
to go but my kid has the test and all
and I kept saying I do got a change and
she said please not yet and so it got
late sorry about the sweatshirt and the
corduroys
and Julie but you're warm yeah yeah I am
one but no I did not hear about the the
script coming my way ten years ago I did
not I have people who represent me that
took it upon themselves to say no to you
guys and and I was at other stuff to do
but but uh but no what happened
eventually was if you don't know have
you heard this story yet she's tuning
out I got good stuff I usually do so so
I I was going to camp for the meyerwitz
this was in 22 years ago right once it
was a teen yeah right and then and my
agency kept saying the safty brothers
want to meet you and I didn't know who
they were so I said why do I need to
meet the safty brothers they said
they're young
very good filmmakers a very hip they
said hip I don't consider you guys here
but now that I know you're considered a
very just I wouldn't use that word I
would just say but at the time I thought
it was like they would skateboarders or
something like that I said I don't know
I said I had time for the safty brothers
let me just do two meyerwitz source and
then when I came back after can they
said to me will you please just look at
one of them movie so I saw a good time
and I was a I could not believe how
great that movie was and I was then I
watched all their movies and I was dying
to meet him and I'm and I said I said
yeah yeah and I texted these guys all
right yeah I texted yeah I said nice
stuff and then they sent me the script
and I read it and I couldn't believe by
the way what a script to get and what
I'd like as an actor you just cycle
every scene you say well that is an
incredible scene that's just scene after
scene was exciting and and I was afraid
and scared at home and my wife said you
can do this and all that stuff but I was
I was terrified at the beginning well
let's talk about some of the reasons why
you should be afraid of a role like that
because I can think of a few yeah yeah I
mean it's it's it's challenging it's
challenging I don't love having
I don't love being naked that's
something that never goes well even
without cameras rolling I'm like I gotta
be naked even walking from the bathroom
to the bedroom and the colonoscopy was a
stock footage we got sure everybody
knows that right I was not that was my
colonoscopy everything is clear yeah no
I was scared of so many things but I
loved it I loved it I was excited just a
just scene after scene was a different
emotion a different thought a different
way to go at things and I never saw
anything coming when I read this script
and then I had no idea what was
happening and what was going to happen
to Howard and and and Julia and anyways
it was once I was in and once I sat down
with the guys and we just talked and
talked and talked I felt more and more
confident how did you prepare to do such
a large role such a crazy role this sort
of this bad romance going what to
between these two people with you know
the delusions the self-deception the
greed and the love it's such an
interesting complicated world and you
you acquitted it beautifully so how did
how did that how'd that come together
for you
well I didn't really prepare that much
because I was told by Josh safty not to
take acting lessons so I basically just
like went to the gym a lot and ate well
and just Smith and Wollensky
and I I remember getting to set and just
being like what if I can't act like what
if I tricked all these people into
thinking I can do this and that screen
test I had that day just miraculously I
could act that one day and I'll never be
able to again and so after the first day
I was very relieved I got through it and
then and I just I got that boost of
confidence and I was like okay I can do
this and I had an incredible teacher you
know just watching him and how he just
can just let himself go and and really
embody this character put his ego aside
and just like you know really immerse
himself and lose himself I was you know
you sir
we did that you were free so free so
that first if we always talk about this
but the first scene we did together was
the scene when I come home and Julia's
been up all night and Josh you want to
say what would Julia did there was a in
this it's in the credit sequence now
actually in the original in the script
it was a six-page scene it wasn't
designed to be part of a credit sequence
and the Edit that it was shot then it
was yeah but I but Jude the character
was supposed to had supposed to been up
all night so Julia thought she would be
method about it and just decided to not
stay up all night so she showed up to a
six-page scene with no sleep and yes and
it was great because but you know and
there's and it's a very difficult scene
if you read the actual the the way it
existed it was had a lot of had a lot of
ups and downs and it was on the page it
was this one scene where the the
plotting that we were trying to do from
on high always felt exposed and and we
hope and you know as directors you just
think okay when we get on the set the
actors will make it alive and that stuff
that you're self-conscious about will
actually disappear and and the two of
them I mean in particular you know Julia
no you know Sandler's standing above but
the way that you were able to I mean
it's a great moment when you're just
like you want to stay mater do you want
to means get a bed in cuddle in the way
that you you just know everything about
the couple in that moment and but I
remember you you were like you were
tired and I we were all like we were all
nervous because it's like you didn't
sleep this is a lot of pages to get
through and if you know with dialogue
the whole the whole script and we would
we had the benefit of following
Sandler's um 50 city tour for his comedy
special and and you know which I was
three and a half hours mature every
night I mean I only get to see an hour
and a half and there's special but it's
a lot and we had it was almost like I've
never seen anything like it the way he
was able to pry his dialogue at one
point we wrote a new monologue the one
opposite tilda swinton on the phone yes
that with the auction manager we we
change that up last second and it was
like the page and a half monologue and I
have thought that we sent it before
lunch started but we just heard they
didn't we thought we did
so he came up to me he's like what's up
with the did you end up changing the
dice okay you didn't get he's like no I
never got it and he's like oh no here
you go and you that's when you feel like
I have a piece of [ __ ] that director
you're gonna give a guy if I die page
and a half of malla and he just went
over to the side for 15 minutes or
something I never seen anything like it
before and he came he's like alright I'm
gonna try to get as much as I can and
and and he did it I mean it was amazing
there was such great chemistry between
the two of you I loved I loved and and
there was that one scene where you
explained about the garnet and I
understand that was something that you
saw lots of the game it's a stone so I
thought maybe we should mention that but
a Kevin and and and when we did scenes
with groups of people when we did
one-on-one scenes he was so focused and
so Latif is incredible in the movie and
likitha but we always talk about he
before the camera look he stays in
character to a lot o when and we were
not rolling or minutes before rolling
least improving so we come in you know
by the time we get to the scene it feels
like it's you know just natural
conversation that we let into and kevin
garnett so I look heath doing this and
he started doing it and then that was
became his habit also but he was a
natural he was amazingly focused in
present and didn't was not unsure ever
he just was like in every scene and
responded and it was improvising
sometimes and he was so on it was
incredible actually I never said we were
all admired how great kg was people
people were like make sure he's not an
actor who became a basketball player you
know it was just don't get it twist it
as a Knick fan this was very difficult
very difficult to not only work with in
collaborate but get to know on a deep
level someone who just we took so much
pleasure Crossin so to speak did get
some inside stories on a lot of the
the legends that he was a part of thank
you guys so much